[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم بلينكن يقول من تل ابيب
انه سيبحث مستقبل الحرب الاسرائيليه على
غزه ويعلن ان زعماء تركيا والاردن وقطر
والامارات والسعوديه مصممون على منع اتساع
دائره الصراع ومسؤولون امريكيون يقولون ان
اسرائيل ابلغت واشنطن انها ستسحب الافا من
قواتها وستقل عملياتها في غزه وهنيه يؤكد
ان الاحتلال لن يستطيع استرداد اسراه
مطلقا الا بالافراج عن جميع الاسرى
الفلسطينيين في سجونه وتجدون المزيد من
اخبار حرب غزه في رابط بالتعليق الاول
ازمه طائرات بوينج
737 ماكس تتفاقم بعد ان قالت شركتا طيران
انهما عثرت على قطعه غير مثبته وبراغ
مفكوكه في عده طائرات وذلك بعد ايام من
تعرض طائره لحادث انفصال مخرج طوارئ اثناء
تحليقها وهو ما اثار مخاوف جديده بشان
كيفيه تصنيع هذه الطائرات الاكثر مبيعا
كاتبان يرفعان دعوه قضائيه في محكمه
مانهاتن الفيدراليه بحق شركه اوبن اي اي
وداعميها المالي مايكروسوفت حيث يتهمان
باساءه استخدام عملهما وانتهاك حقوق الطبع
والنشر الخاصه بهما من خلال تضمين العديد
من كتبهما كجزء من البيانات المستخدمه
لتدريب نموذج الذكاء الاصطناعي تشاد جي بي
تي الاتحاد الالماني يعلن وف اسطوره كره
القدم الالمانيه فرانس بيكن باور عن 78
عاما ولعب اللاعب المعروف بالقيصر دورا
رئيسيا في اعظم انجازات المنتخب الالماني
ويعد احد ثلاث شخصيات رياضيه فقط في
العالم تمكنت من الفوز بكاس العالم كلاعب
ومدرب شكرا للمتابعه الى
اللقاء
ه